hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to levitation simulator in
what is probably three Simulator games
because I'm too lazy to do them one at a
time or I'm too productive whichever one
makes me look better Lexi and make me
look good
thank you
anyway
um
has something to do with
levitating so I'm going to learn
all
I'm [ __ ] sorry what are you saying
that the controls are foreign
they're gone
I was looking at those because
I think it was Jay
okay and then one two what one raises
the arm two lowers the arm three raises
the other arm
oh no
ah four
uh lady are you impressed let me just
raise my arms to the sky oh
[Music]
what happened let me just raise my arms
to the sky and stop him
lady you don't see a thing five
seven six six five five
[Music]
okay that's
what
[Music]
I'm so afraid
so afraid all right
uh excuse me I write this oh okay I
don't
fully understand
[Music]
okay I think I'm starting to get it
ah yes
I
I am in fact
levitating
[Music]
um
wow okay whoa whoa don't touch that lamp
because apparently that's no bueno now
spread them spread them spread them
hey oh my God let me see if I can like
go out the front door or something is
that even something I can do okay okay
no no no no no
not that white is that go that okay okay
I've got this it's a weird combination
of wazed
and not wazed
I J K L whatever that is I
I'm doing it stunningly
somehow I am doing I am going out I'm
free I'm not free this is another
building I will soon be free oh oh how
do I stop how do I stop no no no no no
no no no take two this time
I really know what I'm doing
oh god oh you Goods
okay I am on
oh this my brain hurts I thought I had
it but it turns out I didn't oh okay
okay we levitate We rise
we go further beyond return
upwards and outwards and backwards then
twist
yes just like this
and then with a firm scoot of our butt
ah that goes forwards and backwards and
then the other one goes up and down I oh
I'm doomed I have not I I uh oh
I haven't the foggiest clue why that
happened I wish I had like you guys able
to see what buttons I'm pressing on
screen because it would give a lot more
is that a plug-in is that an overlay
plugin is that a plug-in that I can hang
on let me look that up OBS has a whoa
OBS has a keyboard and mouse overlay
what I'm recording with overlay what oh
god it's GitHub I oh I see go to
download
okay I am literally installing this so
you guys can see what I'm doing because
without this you will have no idea why
I'm getting frustrated this is for you
to join in on the frustration and to
realize that I'm not as dumb as you
think I is
foreign
oh my God it's awful I have to go to
this configuration tool I have to go put
in something here and then I have to I
didn't even do it right I have to go put
a keyboard button in of that with the
key code recording the code that it is
and go I don't even know that's awful I
don't want to do that that's a pain in
the ass this is terrible I'd have to
bind all of it why can't I just you know
what screw this I'm just gonna shout out
what I'm pressing and then you can
understand what that is okay deal deal
double w dot
I can use my mouse
what WS
j i okay
W no s
I know how was I going how was I going
forward then
oh up up
[Music]
so I go up in there too let's make no
sense
however and why does Mouse only move
that leg why is that the only thing that
moves
[Music]
I
wait now
why is s going forward
I have no idea what the controls are
Arrow maybe the arrow too
no it it still doesn't make any sense
so I'm I'm spinning now
and that spin literally there's no
button that will alter that spin I'm
pressing a on the keyboard and it's
doing that
and if I let go of eight stops if I
press D it does that now tell me that
makes sense why does D do this
and a do that
what is that about s does that W does
this I am now moving along a diagonal
that doesn't fully make sense and I'm
drifting slowly to the right
[Music]
oh
wait a minute L goes that way a goes
that oh
ah
I'm understanding now
I'm starting to believe I think it's the
way that the head is oriented so the
problem is once you're rotated like this
it's a very difficult to get the proper
movement to the side because W is still
going slightly up and no matter what I'm
still going slightly up
even s now only Rockets me backwards
foreign
okay
you can kind of control the drift
by combining the up from the right side
with the down from the other side with
the up from the right side and the down
from the other so you can adjust your
trajectory going like that all right I
feel moderately better equipped to
actually handle this I don't know what
the objective is but God damn I am doing
something which is a far cry better than
what I was doing before I think what I
have to do
is go up and then out
nope I gotta go back which if I recall
is this way
and now I'm gonna go oh nope
I don't really know what I'm doing
I don't think I'm going backwards maybe
I just need to go up and out the window
behind me
I'm going
oh my God
okay you know what hey I'm good hey
great game I just forgot that this was
three scary games and I don't actually
have to play that to completion once I'm
done with it I'm done with it and I'm
done with that one hey good game very
fun
moving on
you know that transition thing looks in
just moving on
oh
dude I'm doing it I'm dude Henry chica
not right now I'm in the middle of a
thing
hi this is the thing I'm in the middle
of this
is the new distractible you twos focus
on it not me on it not me there
It's a Wonderful figurine that you can
get through the link in the description
below and it's one of three little
figurines that represent me Bob and Wade
in the distractible podcast and if you
don't know what that is there's going to
be something that pops up right here a
little icon with some text don't know
what distractible is whoa click that and
you can find out it's our podcast where
we talk about funny things to each other
and try to make each other laugh
I think you'll enjoy it and I think
you'll enjoy these so Link in the
description or link up there if you
don't check out one or the other and
then come back to this video something
bad will happen to you something bad
that looks an awful lot like this
the something bad is me
Goodbye Oh no
this is made by the same guy girl I
don't know person human being I hope
there's a tightrope walking simulator
and what this means
oh
oh my God okay left right up wad okay
wad
who
killed me who just killed me okay gotta
get my balance right of course of course
I'll sit
balance balance balance balance balance
hey
[Music]
oh what
oh
I'm on a pirate ship this is the
weirdest camera angle I've ever seen of
anything but anyway
oh
yeah
well this ain't so bad okay this ain't
nearly as bad as the other one the other
one just didn't make any sense at all
and this one at least you can look at
this man's fine ass as he goes through
this tight rope oh my God bird get out
of the way bird get out of the way bird
get out of the way bird get out of the
way get out of the way bird
[Music]
you're serious you serious are you
serious all right fine okay
okay
so if I need to be considerate of
animals
I don't even know what that means
what
maybe animals need to be considerate of
me what do I do about that what am I
supposed to what what
kind of big ass bird just took me away
from to its home also what kind of weird
water reflection is it what I mean I
guess I shouldn't be questioning the
graphics of this game because I don't
think the graphics is the uh
the main idea here but just to be
perfectly honest I'm not fully
understanding what's going on
hi bird what do I do about you I don't
exactly know aha
I just sit down as it turns out
and success
oh God I don't want to know how I shot
that rope over to the other side so
perfectly but here we go I guess
damn the crosswind
and people are going to be awfully upset
when I fall who is there who oh my god
do I have to kill this man to make it
across do I have to step on his fingers
oh wow okay
um
I uh
I I don't really know about this one how
as temperature okay I guess hey
laughs
what
something is what do you mean something
is missing
do I gotta sit on that man's hands
is that what I gotta do because I guess
I'll do it if I really think about I you
know I guess I will but uh hey um feels
like it might be a little bit of you
know Murder and
feel like the most murderous human being
at the moment but squump oh my God and a
bird took him away
Saint Catherine Street E2 oh who are you
down there
why do I see a white glowing eye staring
up at me all right whatever come at me
bro
yeah you better stay down there that's
all I gotta say about that why is the
window open is there a sniper in there
hello hi someone I'm gonna try to
levitate over there are you gonna freak
out when I'm behind you because I really
don't want to deal with that
please don't throw anything at me
please do not throw anything at me don't
oh I knew I knew
fine
please respect the fantasies sure I
don't understand how I was supposed to
beat the levitation simulator this is
this is fine
I'm actually okay with this game this is
this is kind of entertaining it's got an
engaging thing to it it's got a little
bit of a Twist here and there oh
nope
[Laughter]
am I about to commit a crime
am I about to commit some kind of a
crime here wow okay
goodness gracious
uh oh my God I'm I'm doomed oh my God
I'm not sure how to not be but uh
maybe I'll just look I think there was
like a red sweep on the ground before
that one got me
hey
hey
okay this time
I got this
okay there is that uh
all right one last try here
Dodge ha perfect oh
kind how did I get that perfectly last
time I walked right over it before
issue
oh
I'm going for it I'm going for it it's
not gonna give me it's not gonna get me
it's not gonna give me it's not gonna
give me it's not gonna give me it's not
gonna be
this is not gonna get me not gonna give
me not gonna give me not gonna give me
not gonna give me not gonna give me yes
it's perfect it's perfect
how did I do it before I'm not sure I
understand how I did it before huh oh my
God oh my God look at that bod
no no there's no oh God
I all right you know what I've met my
match and you know my match has been met
that was a great stimulator game
I've got another one to cap off this
three simulator games
wonderfully because this one is a
cooking simulator but not like cooking
simulator that I played before this one
is a cooking simulator where you use
as the cooking
[Music]
I think basically what I surmised from
this is that you murder people and you
bake them into goodies and then you sow
those goodies to other humans so that
they can eat them and then you can kill
them and harvest their meat you're
fattening up the town agree to do itself
it's genius anyway it's called ravenous
Devils I think anyway okay day one
[Music]
I barely slept while we were on the
train I did not know he actually sounded
like that wake with a burning fever to
see our new home we got a good deal
buying this place near the river which
had previously been owned by a
well-known barber in the town hey this
house is surprisingly large there's
enough space on the ground floor to turn
it into a beautiful Pub while downstairs
in the basement there's already a large
cozy kitchen I can't wait to get to know
my new customers I've always enjoyed
watching people eating the meals I've
cooked for them lovingly you may wonder
what this
find our successes our loyal clients
obviously fantastic people I feel kind
of sorry about killing them you've
decided to use an unusual ingredient in
our specialties
has resulted the insanely High meat
prices ah but don't worry we don't waste
anything even their clothes are cleverly
reused by Percival they just need a
little patching up and then they are
ready for sale again at full price of
course
we are working so damn hard to do things
right and earn as much money as we can
we're running out of meat fast aren't we
people in this town are like hungry dogs
at least this means that moving here was
the right choice we'll get rich
not the first darling we must keep a low
profile and work hard wait a minute
wait a minute guys
blue red blue red blue red blue red blue
red blue
no all right you know all well too much
we're risking corpse
let's grab this poor Rich later oh he's
oh there's
a guy oh
naked GB
um plopper in
the music is so Sims compared to what's
actually happening in front of here
finally fresh red blue
blue red blue you don't think could it
be
anyway fresh meat trapdoor is working
brilliantly in that it's a hole in the
ground time to stock up on some minced
meat the new meat grinder is great for
lots of prey let's grab the coughs it's
time to cry time to grind oh boy
overlap
oh my God
oh my God I should take a look at my
grandma's recipe book
grandma grandma
hey Grandma where's your recipe book
uh recipes oh grandma oh good
I need flour and minced meat to make a
delicious meat pie I can already smell
it cooking let's take one of the
ingredients
uh-huh
and the other one
yeah the other one bones and all
don't wash your hands or anything I
don't know why I'm worried about hygiene
in this establishment let me take the
tray
when we slap her in
no I just wait
by making some changes I could cook
faster or we could fix like these other
two Ovens that we need more money for
that
hi bye
take a look upstairs how
we ah let's fill it up
is that blood dripping from the ceiling
there that's strange
[Music]
oh my God if my husband is ready too he
has to clean up that mess on the floor
take a look
it's a bloodbath I'll have to clean this
up no one can come up here until there's
no blood left on the floor I'll just mop
it up maybe maybe kill him in the
basement I
maybe is no one gonna suspect anything
people come in here for clothes and then
they never ever ever come out I stole
some clothes that stole I mean
he wasn't using it I see price of course
wasting on one I uh yes let's take a
stolen cloth from the it's not stolen
it's sprawling
let's see and show the definition of
purloined
the more you know it's not going very
fast but it can wait coordination
cooperation at the core of our business
I should adjust the timing of my work
according to hildred's needs the clothes
are finally ready
okay it's still blood squirting out of
everywhere why is there blood squirting
out of everything
is this house made out of blood is that
door made out of are the windows made
out of blood
everything seems to be ready now we can
welcome our new customer I I don't know
maybe the smell would be bad open up
open sesame
[Music]
please come in come in
take what you desire
it's lucky that I filled the display
stand otherwise they'd have been waiting
while I was cooking
every meal has a different price I
cannot give it away for free after all
I'll mark them differently from one
another in the recipe book they will pay
a lot for my delicious meals oh it seems
like someone is looking for a new outfit
you never know if you're working style
would be appreciated by people always
keep in mind to do the best job you can
we don't want bad reviews getting out
I have an appointment pretty soon I need
to take a client's
measurements wait for the client to
arrive okay sure
foreign
Bell going in that room would be a very
bad now we out of the okay I'm taking
measurements and um
massaging shoulders and um
I don't click on this and am I Just
Gonna Keep
I'm gonna generously say massaging this
man oh yeah take this oh oh my God
hildred my love I have a special
delivery for you
one very naked very dead man
who he my love
thinking of you
clients are coming
are you ready
I always have to remind myself to clean
up I'm comforting that hildred is doing
a great job coordination is key
okay right
all right hildred you got it you you got
it I don't need to clean
hildred you're so strong
you're so strong
[Music]
oh that guy had two Meats
what a better what a moon
what a boon well you know this is a
special Slice of Life that you hello
need to free my hands before doing that
excuse the blood squirting out of
everywhere don't mind the floor he does
that from time to time
just like your head and your neck
uh oh there will this uh hold on buddy
pal oh just wait right there I'll be
right with you I'll be right with you oh
uh hold on lady a coordination's key
this is
coming
her coming hildred my love God business
is booming too hard
I don't know why business must boom this
hard
um okay you put that
coordination is key
slap this in here let's see
don't come in here
this is Bowman I like this color
I like this color
all right um okay
well hang on I just need to sell one
more meal and then make one more close
and then kill one more client and then I
did it
okay you'd think that I'd be getting
more blood on myself but that would be a
waste
oh no oh boy oh hildred uh coming at you
all catty Wampus look out there's blood
everywhere
okay
um I did it
starting over is never easy there are a
lot of improvements that need to be made
I wrote this list of things we need to
do to improve our business this way we
will serve as many customers as possible
with fancier shops
let's see what we can approve
what what is it minced meat
steaks
well cooked is better
I'm going back to levitation simulator I
can't let it beat me right there's got
to be a way that this works I was able
to do let me do the bonus stage here
there's a bonus stage okay so I can go
I'm floating I can go up I know I can go
up
[Music]
and I know I can go Downy
and so oh what I don't understand is how
to go any other Direction
that's What uh okay that's what does not
make the most sense to me
is going literally any other direction
than right left
maybe I don't need to no I need to I
need to ah
and just like this
just like this wait no hold on
can't be thus because okay
hold hold
the question is how do I go
forward
maybe oh
is that what I need to do for the arms
do I oh
hey no
why does right click only do that
if I touch that wall with my leg is that
going to be an issue am I going to
instantly die like you've made me die
before
[Music]
oh my God
if I press Everything at Once yeah
what if I go in the other stall
that'll make me feel accomplished I will
feel good about myself if I do that
I'm in it was very bright in here for
some reason
[Music]
Ah that's the way that is the way there
is no way to go forwards or backwards
there is no way it was all the clever
ruse
all of it was a clever ruse
I see now
you have to go through this blind with
faith that is the key to levitation the
ultimate levitation
[Music]
just like that you have to feel
ultimate
calm The Only Way Forward
why
[Applause]
one more try what a silly grab bag of uh
Simulator games
I haven't done anything that like wasn't
a three scary games but originally I
always had this intention that I was
gonna do like three anything games and I
had like three weird games uh three
awesome games or whatever so this is
three Simulator games and you get what
you get my mouse has been in the way the
entire time but that's okay okay so what
I need to do is I need to pick up speed
going to the right that's what I gotta
do I gotta go quick I gotta go quick and
I gotta go accurately which means that I
gotta pick up some goddamn speed or else
I am going to die I oh okay I need even
more speed than that so somehow
I have to get maximum speed here we go
[Music]
come on there we go there we go there we
go now we're getting it now we're now
we're getting now we're getting oh no
that's how am I supposed to get any
speed you don't even give me a chance
[Music]
easy easy okay here we go
what we do this is what we do I'm done
all right cool well that was three
simulator games
play this for yourself the link is in
the description thank you everybody so
much for watching hey if you want to
simulate having a great time with a
great show why don't you play
why don't you watch in space with
markiplier hey why don't you listen to
distractible hey why don't you listen to
go my favorite sports team check them
all out they're in the description lots
of cool funny stuff there thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you or uh actually as
always I will be levitating slowly into
your bedroom window at exactly 12 41
tonight
in the next video bye-bye
I'm not lying
[Music]
thank you